All right. Anything in my teeth?
As a former professor who taught entrepreneurship, I often get asked:
"What are the secrets to good leadership?"
Here's one piece of advice: Be nice! Now,
niceness might seem like a naive
strategy, especially in this climate. It
feels like our society today has become
a battle of competing pessimisms.
Wouldn't an actively nice leader seem
out of place? But that's exactly the
point! These days, warm heartedness is
radical and unexpected... and it turns out,
also very effective. In one 2013 study,
researchers found that a positive kind
leader is judged to be 132 percent more
effective than an unpleasant leader. Now,
niceness does not mean we need fewer
disagreements – or less debate. Business
and policy require a healthy competition
of ideas. But our intellectual contest
should be fierce and friendly at the
same time. So leaders: Get nice! It will
help you build a sustainable success and a better world!
To learn more about the
competitive advantage of being nice,
click the links in the description below.
Also, let us know what other topics you
want AEI scholars to cover in 60 seconds.